I think considering the life of a child  it has to be encompassed of who is  actually raising that child you know the  child isn't just born and then becomes  its own soul and its own being it's  raised by as a byproduct of what the  parent currently is and the pattern and  the and the blueprint that the parent  has created and if you haven't yourself  done the work to enable yourself to be  the best possible parent of only  yourself and your inner child  to then be expected to raise another  child would actually be  a discredit to The Unborn being I think  like  to become a parent is to know that  you're ready  to raise another being and consider that  actually you're passing on your  blueprint and if you still carry heavy  trauma then how can you raise another  being to its best possible  potential of Soul like  I feel like people raised kids with  trauma all the time before yeah